oh they are
now we run back in 2003 Thomas Brodie
sane star played Sam a lovesick boy
running from airport security in Love
Actually
and now in a strange twist of fate the
actor is running from the law again this
time in real life while taping the
film's 20th anniversary reunion special
with Diane Sawyer now we run Diane sat
down with members of the cast and crew
to talk about the holiday classic and
return to the iconic London bench where
Thomas filmed this scene with his
on-screen stepdad Liam Neeson that's my
liver relieved
I thought it would be something worse
worse than the total Agony of being in
love
you're right can you believe it's been
20 years no when I heard about this I
didn't even realize it had been 20
minutes really yeah I couldn't believe
it I watched it for the first time this
past Christmas since the premiere
I'd forgotten how good it was yeah that
means Thomas hadn't watched Love
Actually since ET was with him two
decades ago
movie have you seen it yet yeah I've
seen it once yeah what did you think I
thought it was really good actually I
really enjoyed it but that trip down
memory lane with Diane ended quickly
when a producer chimed in to wrap it up
that warning might have stopped Thomas
and Diane but we have a feeling it
wouldn't have stopped Sam
[Music]
um well it's just a feel-good film
really I mean you can't really hate it
it's fun
you trust me I trust you
back in 2003 Thomas opened up to ET
about working with Liam
really nice guy
and the love was mutual oh it's a good
guy okay
yeah yeah he was and he uh you know he
raises your game he raised your game oh
absolutely did you have to teach him a
lot no he taught me a lot really
very good actor yeah I'd love to do
something with him again there isn't
just one person for each of us that was
for you
and there is for me
she's the one the two haven't reunited
on screen yet but Thomas still has
nothing but rave reviews for the
a-lister Liam was amazing he treated me
like his son he was absolutely lovely to
me just created this environment where I
was very comfortable but we can't talk
about Thomas in Love Actually without
mentioning that epic drum scene so to
send you off here's Sam rocking out in
the Name of Love
[Music]
thank you